and we're live what's up everybody it's
uh
it's us how's it going jt
it's going well how are you i'm good man
i'm good it's it's time
it's time for tournament art can you
believe it i can't
i'm actually a little bit nervous
because i want my team to win
dude i feel like i've been planning this
for months but it's actually only been
like
i don't know like three weeks maybe
ugh i'm so ready i'm so ready
what a beautiful event right like eight
of your favorite youtubers
battling it out yes over the 64 squares
it's gonna be it's gonna be sick let's
go ahead and just explain the tournament
for anyone
who is uh just tuning in and not sure
what this is about to be
so we have found eight
of i i'm gonna i'm gonna be biased to
say eight of my favorite
anime youtube content creators this all
actually started off of a tweet
that uh sea dog va who is competing in
the tournament
sent out just telling the community like
hey would you be interested in something
like this
and uh and they responded in numbers so
trust.com our team reached out and we
said you know you guys want to do
something and they said yeah so
here we are we we are on day one this is
round one we're gonna do the top of the
bracket today
the bottom of the bracket tomorrow you
see there's dates and times next to
these pairings
and they're competing for a
piece of a five thousand dollar prize
pool two thousand dollars is going to go
to the first place
uh thousand per second we will have a
third place match to settle who uh
who wins third it's eight hundred
dollars four hundred for fourth and then
fifth through eighth place they're all
going to get 200 bucks each so
everybody's gonna get something for
competing
which is pretty awesome and um
i i don't know what else to say we've
got two match-ups today
and we're going to start out with
rustage versus sid snap i mean uh so jt
like i'm super stoked for this like
what do you what do you think is going
to happen in this first match
i think there are going to be a lot of
blunders and
a lot of exciting chess so i can't wait
to analyze and go
over this game with you yeah i mean i
i've watched them practice and they're
both attackers
right so this is going to be these games
are gonna be nuts i think
like they're they're just they're both
gonna go hard right at the start
and uh and it'll just be super tactical
and then um
and then we'll interview those players
after the first match before we move on
to the second
event of the night egoc vs
mother's basement now these guys like
i've heard that there's a bit of a
rivalry already
sort of in the in the anituber sphere
between these two fellas so like we're
we're
we're in for some drama i think
yeah but again i want my team to win so
i of course i want everybody to have fun
but
yeah i'm rooting for my team now for
anyone who doesn't know what
what uh what you might mean by that we
have actually provided one
hour of uh one-on-one training
for each of these players they're going
to be competing over the weekend
uh and so team japanese tutor i'm gonna
call it
uh versus team gm canty you
you guys gave uh an hour of your time to
each of these players
to teach them the basics and make sure
that they go in with a solid foundation
uh so that we could level the playing
field because we've got people of
varying levels of experience with chess
from like some
to none and we wanted to make sure that
they that they really uh
understood the fundamentals and now so
like what would you say
are sort of just like the the very
essential things
for people new to chess to think about
when they're
playing their first games
not to get frustrated within the first
two games right so if you lose
the more you lose the more you learn how
not to lose
right and so that should kind of
put you on track to start learning and
start getting better
and i think the one key thing is not to
get frustrated and then
study some openings study some tactics
do some end games do some middle games
and then
repeat that process into your
grandmaster and you actually do
coaching yourself one-on-one you do
tutoring uh
online and also you uploaded all of the
streams that you did with your four uh
students from this competition to your
youtube channel right
yeah so all all of the lessons with sea
dog giga
uh the anime man and sid i uploaded to
my youtube channel it's
youtube japanese students right down
there and thank you
um but yeah it was amazing um they were
all different kinds of players
so i had to take each one of their style
and make a lesson
cater to that so it was really it was a
really interesting process
those those were a lot of fun to watch
and people should definitely go to your
youtube channel
and um check them out but guys we are we
are five minutes away
from the first set of games like it's
crazy i wanna i wanna pull up
uh uh uh the competitors starting with
uh
we've got a little look at sid she
is live on sid snap on twitch and she
looks like she's getting ready to go
we've also got
rustage streaming at rustic underscore
on twitch as well you guys can watch the
official coverage here and you can also
go check them out and wait a minute why
did sid just slap
herself she just slapped herself in the
face
you do have to remember that it is a 9
a.m in japan right now that's true yes
so sid is in japan and rustic is in the
uk
so for him it's actually very late it's
like coming up on i think
one a.m over there is it three
wait where is it i think it's like one
i'm terrible at math so please don't
hold me to that guys but
i'm pretty sure that's the case anyways
doesn't matter the fact is
we are like four minutes away now from
some really exciting chess
uh we might as well go ahead and get
these players on camera too at this
point so
um what what what i want to say i want
people to know about rustic right this
kid has taken this so seriously
like it's crazy like uh
he i caught him so he started his stream
pretty early today
and a few moments ago i actually caught
him going into sid's game history
on chess.com and scrolling through her
more recent games so he's
actually like he's actually sizing up
his opponent before this
yeah he's doing some high level tactics
he's definitely uh using some five head
tactics there
looking his up his opponent's openings
and making sure that he's prepared for
them
so i i told you we're gonna see some
exciting chess here
have you did you ask sid during your
your lesson with
her if she was gonna do the same and
like look in on his stuff or
is she really just gonna focus on her
training and her practice
i think she's gonna focus on her
training and her practice um
she is quite a genius when it comes to
like
attacking sometimes she finds some moves
that like the computer says is bad and
then it turns out to be good
so let's see it's very interesting so
like sometimes it's really bad
yeah but then sometimes it's really good
so there's like kind of no gray
area there's nothing in the middle uh
but for me i think rustage is a little
bit more solid
but i think sid is a little bit more
creative
and so that's i think what we're gonna
see here today and let's see
it's really going to bring about some
exciting chess and you know you
mentioned the engine so i want to point
out for anyone watching who is not sure
what that bar is
on the left-hand side there of the the
chessboard
that is going to be sort of like a
living engine analysis
of what the what the advantage is
in the current position as the game goes
so if the white bar gets larger that
means the engine believes that white is
doing better
uh in a sort of pure evaluation if
everyone were to play perfect moves
from that position on uh then
that would represent what the current
advantage is um and obviously if black's
bar is bigger then it's
trying to tell you that black is
probably doing better it may be much
better the bar might be almost
completely solid black and at that point
black is probably not that far away from
finding a good checkmate but um
but i have a feeling this thing is going
to go like crazy
oh yeah and one of the other things i
want to say about the engine that i tell
beginners all the time is like
you want to analyze your games after you
play them if you're going to play on
on the site but you also don't
necessarily want to take it too
seriously when you're still learning the
game right
i think one of the best practices for
beginners to analyze their games
is to actually review it without the
engine
first see where they made their mistake
and then use the engine to kind of check
their analysis
well we're about to see it it's a minute
away
guys i'm excited it is crazy when this
is like a story like when the clock
strikes
five you know like i'm ready i'm ready
our staff
is behind the scenes getting ready to
trigger the
games so they are going to play two
games everybody
this is a best of two effectively uh
they will play
one game with each color so starting as
white and starting as black
they only need a win and a draw in order
to win
their match for this round so 1.5 points
right that's one point for a win
half a point for a draw obviously a loss
is zero
so whoever can get 1.5 or better
is gonna take it now if they're both
tied after those two games let's say
they draw both games or one of them wins
a game and the other one wins the other
game
then they will go into a death match
which is gonna be
a much faster time control it'll be
three
plus zero and the game has started
and they'll play those three plus zero
games until somebody wins so here we go
all right let's do this sid snap starts
with the white pieces
and here we have i think the structure
comes from an exchange
caro khan very solid
okay yep so now white has the obvious
tension right now is on d5 right
knight takes knight takes uh is not a
great move for white so
hopefully sid just continues to develop
her pieces and get castled
right right um in our lesson we talked
about taking the center and the center
being important so that's actually a
pretty good move
bishop to b5 um
i think kind of holds attention and i
think the better move there
might have been bishop d7 but um i think
they're about equal so far
yeah i thought there was going to be a
blunder on move five yeah right i mean
and that that bishop move kind of goes
for her style right it's like just get
her pieces out there
throw in a check see what he does and
then she's castled i mean they're both
doing great they're developing they're
castling like wow
i would really love to see the move d4
here d4 opening up the c1 bishop
okay and also attacking right gaining a
tempo on the bishop
forcing that bishop to go back tempo is
time and chance right so forcing the
bishop to go back
and then you're free to do another move
[Music]
g3 seems a little bit weakening i i
really prefer d4 so
if i think the critical move for both
players right now is the move d4
because if rostich can get the movement
d4 in right now
forcing that knight away and like let's
say the knight goes to a4 then we have
d4 for black yep yeah
yeah i think both players should play d4
right now i think that's a critical move
um okay castle very solid very solid get
your king safe no
and you know what d4 it might be a
little bit like
committing too much over committing and
here sid has made a pretty big mistake
she's moved that bishop now three times
in the opening
yep started out here now back and now
moved once again
that's kind of what we we tell people
that's a no-no right don't don't move
the same piece more than once until
you've developed all of your pieces
she still needs to find a job for this
bishop and figure out ways to start
controlling the center
although it's not lost
can take the advantage i think right now
e5 with the threat of e4
is extremely strong
so if i think russiag might play a move
like gaff rookie aye not if you're
now you have to move that bishop again
the bishop on d3 now has to move again
so that pawn can move either to d3 or d4
and i i don't like
the position that sid has right now but
it's still
kind of a little bit early you still
have to remember
that they're not engines they're not
grand masters right
um so i like that russell is developing
his pieces
yeah i think he should be a little bit
more forceful with the move like e5
yes moving the bishop beautiful i love
him yeah so i mean this could have just
stayed there this whole time though you
know
okay and he's going for your plan of
going ahead now open up the center now
that you've got some people
tying down some key squares
the other thing i want to mention that i
really like so far is that they're both
even on the clock i thought that maybe
rustage would
be a little too much in his head while
giving sid a time advantage but so far
they're pretty even
yeah i i am liking russell's position
after
queen to e2
the queen to d6 um i so i think the plan
here
it should be to the bishop should
capture on c6 and then to play
d4 i love this move i love the move d4
i but okay now she's trying to develop
the bishop to b2
great move great idea finally developing
that bishop
yep start to fight for that square right
but the move e4 is going to be
extremely annoying when it comes if it
ever comes
well we'll see we'll see uh you know i i
look at this
and i'm i'm just waiting for plans to
start to emerge right you've got your
pieces developed you've got your kinks
castled
all right so now how are you gonna go go
for checkmate right how are you gonna
start to win material
i mean obviously oh okay
that that actually seems like it's just
gonna
it's just gonna help white kind of do
what they already want to do maybe
yeah i think the best move here is
bishop catcher's c6
and after they recapture maybe something
like knight a4
really yeah because
if if we take on c6 they take on
f1 then we're just able to take but we
can get kind of out of that bad position
and our weaknesses are on the light
squares
right so if they have no lights for a
bishop then we can kind of hold them
but i um
i think the work that rustage put in
was really beneficial right now
bishop g4 threatens a really nice move
e4 because the knight is pinned yes
and i went over this in in my lesson
with uh
honor uh or with cdawg
you put pressure on the pin pieces so
for those of you uh uh who miss out on
that that's
all the youtube as well uh you put pp on
the pp right yeah and
are you are you are you gonna get a
night either way because after this you
you
either decide to let it take on the next
turn or you take with the other knight
and then there's some sort of way of
getting compensation by trading that one
it's tough because the queen doesn't
really have any good square to go to
like you can't go to d3 because e4 comes
right
d3 okay recognizing that e4 is going to
be an issue
but yeah now we have amazing moves here
and it's not looking that good that's it
there's a beautiful move attacking the
knight and the queen at the same time
you know there's a lot of patience here
a lot more patience than i thought
either of these players would really
have
right i mean there's so much material
still
they're just kind of jocking for control
which i which i think is unexpected
based on what i've seen from their
practice yeah i thought they were going
to be more aggressive but you know what
it's there it's a high stakes tournament
e4
very nice okay now sid's got some big
decisions to make here
okay takes with the pawn all right now
we're gonna start to see it really
happen
yeah yeah
i think we have to hope for the queen
trade
where we play queen d2 and hope that
russia
takes the queen interest in the knight
that that's the one trick that i see
here
are you gonna are you gonna bring this
bishop back into the game once this pawn
is gone rather than trading it on this
side
um
it just depends on what the other side
ouch oh
no ouch town
ah there it goes that's the first botes
gambit of the tournament
and sid is not happy with that yeah
it was kind of a delayed reaction as
well oh yeah
yeah it took a moment to sink in but she
realized
and that's the danger right that's the
danger of of not dealing with those
threats right those pins
if you let them sit you might forget
about them
right and look at the four different
moves that
she played with the bishop that could
have been used to avoid potential
situations like this
yeah i mean her bishop might have had a
job that rooks could have been connected
there's definitely
there's definitely some lessons that
hopefully she takes with her into the
next game is black
now uh pretty much rustage just has to
you know maybe
start just trading everything off right
now that you're up significant material
right go ahead and take away as many
pieces as possible
from sid so she has very few tools left
in the toolbox
to try to fight off a checkmate but also
remember guys it's never over until it's
over
right you always have to keep writing
and just be vigilant
and be tenacious when you're playing
chess
so rustage is uh basically saying what
are you gonna do with this bishop now
make a decision if you trade it's great
for me if you move it away fine because
then i can
forget about that whole situation on
that side of the board and just start
attacking right
right i like bishop c4 a lot and
there are a lot of great moves for black
here
95 being one of them right covering f7
and attacking the c4 bishop
yep
well let's uh let's let's listen in a
little bit i want to hear what sid
is saying right now in her stream so you
want to you want to
give a little listen in let's do it
let's do it
and we'll get sid's audio here she is
she's feeling the pressure for sure yeah
oh man
just trying to think what to do
75 is another great move is she just
totally checking out at this point and
ready for the next game
i hope that she isn't and you know
there's still a chance daniel
let's play this game huh wait do not
resign let's do it yeah let's go
do not give up i'm here to kill
but not to be killed no i'm here to
murder
every single thing that has ever
ever ever
cross paths on me and that is just a
fact
of life here like i'm here for whatever
so i'm going to take a little guess here
and see what uh you know
what's in the store for a little danny
boy huh
um would you want to trade when you're
this far down in material
i i think bishop d2 was the right move
let's go bishop would have been better
than bishop e3
[Music]
remember it's not over till it's over
and you know five minutes left
there's so many tactics here i mean you
accidentally again if she
she forgets that there's this pressure
here on the rook on a1
i mean that that that's with it that
comes with a check too i mean
wow rustage has a lot a lot of potential
here
wow very very nice very solid rook a
queen capture c3
very solid
just see how he closes it out let's
actually take a listen in on restage now
and uh see what
see what's going on here how how is he
gonna finish this game
which is a better trait than she's um
again but i'm running out of time i'm
already down half my time
she's using up a lot of her time too but
not quite as much as me if this
does go down to the time she will win
so i just got to make sure that she
doesn't
if i move if i move my horse here it
will stop the king from going to either
one of these squares
so if i do force her to go down here
with the the queen
uh
i should probably move this over here to
protect this file now that i think about
it because it's a completely empty file
and then i can move down there and
that's a check he's making a lot of
great points
yeah i mean you you know he's he's
working on some players sorry there's so
many arrows on the screen okay that's
what you have to do on that now
it's what i wanted to do and how she's
done it
that's rare at the beginning fine
because i think i could just trade here
uh i don't mind losing this i think
because
i'm in a a position now where i think
trading is a little bit better
um you can hear the attention no no no
no
he so wants to win uh
that would be bad too if it went up
there
yeah i mean this is great if we come
back to the chess i mean like
he's he's talking to himself right i do
that right
try to just talk out all the plans like
what are all the possibilities even if
they're bad let me get them out there
let me think about them do a little bit
of surface calculation and then
you know bail on the things that don't
make any sense but just like get those
get those get those juices flowing right
right we definitely you know we need
some creativity
from both sides here and russ is just
really taking his time
i like that he's taking his time even
though he has less time than her
he's utilizing his time to create an
advantage
for that when he has less time he can
play a bit quicker
yeah and there goes another rook
oh no oh boy off the deep end
no sid no
ah now obviously rustage hasn't just
taken it right away because he's worried
about tricks right he's like okay is
this a trap
let me make sure this isn't she's not
just giving me free stuff
got to be certain you know so i think
that's time well spent even though he is
uh um has a minute less on the clock
than sid does
he's just got more opportunities so so
he's going to make that time up later
once he clarifies the position and
trades down some of these pieces
i mean by the way there's also a free
night on live
i'm just saying everything
is free but gives a check right
yeah that's okay like see if there's see
if there's a way to check mate there
there really
isn't just yet but once he starts
bringing some other pieces to bear he'll
have something
you know just get rid of all this peace
all that all this material that's just
gobble up all this free stuff
i'm thinking what happens if he allows
sid to trick him
okay and lets her maybe attack
that might get dangerous maybe if he's
trying too much maybe he goes after that
pawn
right it's a free pawn on a2 please we
have three pieces attacking on f7
right and can we do a windmill tactic
can we
um right and a windmill is where you can
go with the knight back and forth back
and forth maybe force a draw or maybe
you'll win
yep let's see if sid obviously she has
to realize that she's got a lot of
hanging material first
deal with those things and if if there's
a creative way to deal with that
that also you know bring some threats
oh man he found it russ has found it
yeah and you can see on camera he's
absolutely stoked he knows that there's
a win here and we
i talked with him a little bit about it
uh before the tournament when you know
there's a win
right just find a simple enough plan to
seal the deal
and then pursue that right because if
you this is advice that i got from danny
when he would watch me play sometimes
is you know you're going to burn a lot
of time on the clock if you try to be
super accurate when if you know you're
winning
and you can just come up with a clear
path to success that's simple enough and
safe enough
just chase that right don't don't end up
running out of time
in a winning position
and now under two minutes
yep a little worried about that let's
see if he
has sp quick
yep he's finding all the free stuff
now he's just got to trade off what's
left and finish the game
and sid you know she's going to come
back right hopefully she realizes maybe
she was moving a little bit too quickly
right putting her pieces in danger and
maybe she'll be more cautious
unfortunately she has to play the next
game as black so there's already that
disadvantage
but i think at this level i i think it
really doesn't matter who goes first
i guess you can speak some of the game
but i think that it really only matters
when you're a
just giving it all away all right sid
you're gonna have to come back in the
second game here
but also i mean look at russia's clock
minute 48
he might not be able to close it out in
time
i mean how would you do this as black
just to get it done
as black um okay so yeah
oh that's one of the plans right just
get the king away maybe
put the queen on uh on d1 try to check
from the light squares
right so i'm thinking about a plan like
maybe rook b1 queen d1
queen to h5 me because the king cannot
go to f3
okay she's already moving out but you
know now her king is exposed right
and i think there's a lot of ways to
meet here and russell just has to pick
a good one gotta pick something a minute
and a half under a minute and a half
yeah there's a really nice plan of maybe
g5
g4 and then knight to
f3 if the game goes h for me
[Music]
well let's listen in on uh restage real
quick and see if he can work this out
the queen here so i blocked this file
yep the idea here now is to create these
addresses the idea here now is if i move
this here and take here
that's checkmate it's not she can move
up there it's not checkmate
oh no
i'm running out of time
oh no he's got the right idea though
just get the queen over there where it
can do some work
yeah if i move this wait i can move here
right is that checkmate
is that checkmate no why is that not
checkmate
it's protected
and now that's not protected anymore
yeah gotta be super careful here i can't
make this here
because then he'll take a lot of time if
i move this here
he can he can take
30 seconds see a scramble
in a pickle now if i move this here it
protects both of these squares
you can't take cause of this ouch um
and now that this square is protected i
can move this here and i think that
might be checkmate
no i forgot to do that almost almost
almost
if you can find the right move
wow wow very nice very nice
wait there he goes okay there he goes 25
seconds left
force me in one move yep and he wasn't
wasn't tempted to take that rook
you know go after check babe yeah
15 seconds left oh mate is on the board
the maid is on the board yeah i think
that's it for the trick
on time just to go for the tricks she's
gonna move this here but then i just
take it with the
this if i move up here is that checkmate
wow
i think that might be and let's watch
him finish this thing yes
23 seconds remaining i got it uh
yeah and russ is super stoked he gets
that first win
wow wow you know what do you
what do you think honestly it's amazing
for
you guys who have not played adjusting
especially in a high pressure situation
like this one where you're in the
tournament
money's on the line like your brain is
working overtime
and thinking much faster and just you're
always doubting yourself
and it's very tough so when you get that
win
it's just the best feeling in the world
and i know how he's feeling
yeah i i i felt that my first tournament
win
you were there with me in vegas during
the national open
man i walked out of that room so stoked
so
we we definitely know the feeling and
now sid
has got to turn this thing around
she she's in a must-win situation if she
does not win this game
then that is it rustage moves on in the
bracket
so uh what are you seeing so far in
these opening moves i i don't like the
bishop on a6 and i don't don't like the
pawns you know
in our lesson we talked about
controlling the center
and a lot about you know where you
should put your pieces
um so you can develop and
the bishop okay the bishop on e6 is
not the worst place piece maybe you can
have an idea of playing something like
bishop f7 bishop h5 and
activating it on that line and i do like
the control that she has
over e4 if we don't blunder
the queen away here okay great
and now we have a very firm grip on e4
which is a big idea um
it almost looks like a stonewall
structure except castle queenside
i mean you could have taken with the
bishop there as well right to maintain
your pawn structure
so now yeah dealing with these double
pawns in the center but for now it's
okay
right yeah um and you mentioned a great
point
there are the pawns and it's blocking
the bishop and as long as the bishop
stays there
we're talking about the bishop on e6
that bishop can never act
have access to the h2 uh to b8 diagonal
got to do something with these puns to
get that bishop moving or like you said
just get it mobile
in some other way i yeah i think the
idea
might be to activate our sulfur uh sid
to activate the bishop on f um
on e6 maybe by playing bishop f7 bishop
e8 moving the queen somewhere and then
maybe maybe
even into e6 and then trying to activate
it on that line
that's a lot of work to have to do now
c4 d4 was very strong
i really like c4 so
russet's putting in a lot of work i
didn't expect to see this like
high quality of a game like this is
actually some really good chess
that russia's showing yeah i'm impressed
i mean
the fact is this this i mean this is
going to be great
after you you know uh maybe trade off
these things with the discovered
attack get your rooks in there i mean
like russell just figuring out like
how to how to control the center how to
break things open and get active
we actually have an opportunity for sid
right now if d capture c4
right now if bishop captures c4 you know
we just take oh there we go and they're
doing it
yep
you have to play bishop e2 here bishop
e2 or bishop c2
you cannot take really
now why is that because we uh
because you we can just take the bishop
on c4
oh we're not going to take the queen
drop a piece after the trades aha
i did not see that
and the queen is adequately uh defended
and just like that i thought sid was
actually in a worse position but
i think right now it's about even maybe
white is slightly better after the
trades
but because of black's immobile pieces
but now
we have resolved the issue with the
lights for pressure for black basically
now we have to deal with it
whoa whoa okay
so we have a couple of good moves here
okay and
the first one and i don't expect them to
find okay that was the second best move
yeah okay c5
working the pin right yep
and you have it you have it do you have
it here i don't think so i don't think
you
you have it here i think c5 is still
good c5 between a6 and then king v8
and i think you now have control to
default your like square bishop is the
good bishop
right and your knight can get into the
game very easily so i i'm liking the
position
for uh sid right now up a piece yep yeah
and up on the clock yet yep sid also
looks a little bit more confident now on
the clock i think she can sense that
she's doing better here
yeah wow we we might have a match
we might we might end up getting dead
can you have this great
yo like i i bet you oh man 3-0
sudden death would be so hype between so
i actually prepared her for that
okay yeah so in our lesson i said
we might go to the final game so let's
play some bullet
and so i took like 15 seconds and i gave
her like
about three minutes whoa did sid just
give back some material here with that
pawn move
i yeah queen a6 would have been a
killer here but i think here we just
have to play
we can't let them check us c5 doesn't
really work anymore
uh so we need to play king beast b8 or
b7
i mean a6 is a thorn in the side but g5
is a very
really strong move but
so two possibilities yeah queen a6
really nice move okay and now how do you
follow up as white after the king moves
then we play rook a to d1
right and then the idea is to play maybe
knight b5
hitting the queen and then trying to
check me yeah
that's a little bit too hasty yep c6
best move here is c6
blocking everything attacking the knight
and preventing the mate
c6 you have to find c6 if you do not
yeah well c5 is also good but
we need c6 well let's listen in on sid
real quick and see if this uh
spots the danger roshio
uh oh
she allows the check
oh only one and then queen a1 is made at
this point
is one move away from closing out the
match
wow
no way no way no way
no oh no
oh [__] oh that is so troublesome
in japanese
instant translation oh my what is
happening
oh my goodness well i mean
through all that she's found a way to
get away from the immediate threat but
my goodness how it
oh my gosh there's made him one there's
still made on the board queen takes c7
and that's it
yep not with the right piece but could
still do this
i mean yeah you know the king is gonna
run to yep d8 and now you have to
you have to go about it another way but
russia is still obviously with the
advantage here
yeah i think just rook to b7
yeah or yep queen b8 yep it's over
rustage wins his first match and you can
see he's absolutely
losing his mind yes i i thought he was
gonna play rook b7 there
i really thought he was focused on that
rook so i really thought
wow 2-0 and that's it
the first match is over rustage has
taken it and we'll move on
to face either cdog or
super eye patch in the next round we are
going to go to our first commercial
break
and when we come back we will interview
both of the players
so stick around everyone and we will see
you
in just a moment
[Music]
so
thank you we're back
with sid and rustage what's up
what is going down in chess town
[Laughter]
that was such an awesome exciting match
you guys
so jt i mean let let's maybe
start by going over a little bit on that
that last game
that second game uh sure yeah
go ahead can i just say that i i don't
know if you noticed but i thought i had
a checkmate when i didn't that entire
time when i was moving my queen and
knight over i thought when i moved my
queen up to that square i can't read
what it's called a2 maybe
um i thought oh that's checkmate because
it's protected by the
by the horsey and uh she can't go
anywhere but she could just move the
queen to the right
and i didn't see it i think i was
blundering every move of that
yeah let's uh maybe you want to pull up
that position uh
jt and we'll we'll start maybe at that
towards the end and
and move backwards then sure all right
so let's see where i i think i would
have done a lot worse in that game if
she
take my horse yeah that was a deciding
move
let's get in here
yeah so i forced her to move the king
over
which is what i wanted to do and then i
then i moved my i moved the pawn so that
i could move the the knight without it
just being taken by the queen
then see i see the game's like that's
bad um
i thought now if i move my queen up i
would win
because i thought i can't take the queen
i just didn't even think about that
space
i also sometimes think the queen can
move like horses as well
um but yeah i
i this that's where i that's where i
sell for me and
yeah so it was actually really good in
the position that we have
on the screen right now with after
knight b5
you're threatening you know queen
captures
eight seven king to c8 and then
queen to aa checkmate right but actually
if we go
one move before this before you played
knight b5
i think a stronger move would have been
rook to d1 because now the queen
has to kind of find a space and then
queen rook a to d1
yeah okay okay
right and i think that might have been a
little bit stronger
because then when we play knight to b5
and you're in
now you were attacking the queen as well
so they have to deal with that
right so you want to make um threats
um right right
in that first game i had this little bit
where i i felt like i pinced it two of a
piece
making one i pinched the other two maybe
i can't remember
um that first game was very stressful
because i knew i was winning but i
almost ran out of time
i know i was i was so
i i what i had one with 20 seconds left
yeah yeah i was that close to just and i
i knew i was like i just gotta move
these pieces to the right
and i i [__] up i took my brook or
something
oh yeah now sid you
obviously in the second game were in a
must-win position here right
and so did you do you have a sense of
like
where you were at how you were doing if
you had the advantage at any point in
this game
um i wouldn't honestly say i had
any particular advantage at all in the
second game i think
definitely when we had the little mini
massacre near the end
uh i mean it was really i think we all
lost
quite a few important pieces
i gotta kill everything in my path
you might even interject here yeah
we you were actually destroying him in
the second game
[Laughter]
yeah so if we can go back to uh i
believe
it's when he played knight to d4 so i
believe that's move
12. yeah okay where i [__] up because
i thought i had a checkmate but
right here we have a very powerful move
now you you found the best like one of
the best moves
sea catchers on um
the bishop that was one of my biggest
mistakes i was i i kicked myself
like that bishop or and i was like oh
this
this bishop's dead it's gonna die anyway
so i'm just gonna move this horse
and try and set something up but
actually
there's a slightly better move and you
know you have to do pp on the pp right
put pressure on the pin
piece and right now the pin is on
the knight right we're pinning the
knight because if the knight moves then
we take the bishop
right so if you play c5 here
if black plays c5 and let's say knight
takes
on e6 then queen takes on e6 and guess
what
now our rook is pinning the bishop to
the queen
so that would have been you know a next
level threat and we want win a piece and
also
have a lot of pressure so much pressure
here in the center
but i'm sure i'm an idiot
but i think but i think even after this
even after the queen captures
right so c captures d3 it happens
and then queen captures d3 here again
c5 put pressure on the pin piece
you know what guys i mean ultimately
the question is did you have
a good time was this fun i i okay
sydney did you have fun because i mean i
had fun
like even though i lost i would hope not
terribly i you know in the grand scheme
of things like i learned how to play
channels
you know i you know i don't know i
learned how to play chess
i didn't i didn't feel like i was having
an easy time with it like i was
if you listened to my stream i was
talking non-stop
talking out all of my moves and i was
very stressed especially at the end of
the first game
where i had no time left um i was and
actually in that second game where i
when you move that pawn next to my
bishop i i have this terrible habit of
whenever an opponent plays a good move
against me shutting down and not doing
anything
i think yeah that's what yeah so once
you once you did that i almost like
i almost like moved my horse up to
threaten the queen and start like going
crazy
but i had to calm myself down at that
moment well you still won
daniel um
don't worry i i won't rob it
[Laughter]
i know but we are different people well
guys
uh that was really entertaining to watch
thank you so much
sid i'm sorry did not go your way
rustage
good luck in the next round and um
and have a great night and and russiage
we will see you
uh in a couple days yeah all right have
a good night guys
bye goodbye thank you bye-bye
and there you have it rustage moves on
and will face
the winner of tomorrow's match between
sea dog
and super eye patch in the meantime
we have another match up coming
up next ego
versus mother's basement i is this the
one
that people were really waiting for like
this is gonna be
intense yeah
um this is gonna be i heard they have a
rivalry and
i'm rooting for giggup but um i just
want him to play calm chest
he's honestly a really smart person i
think he has a masters in engineering
really he likes to take apart things
yeah well um so
i'm really rooting for him we will see
if he
can take his opponent's opportunities
away we will be
back in just a couple minutes for
the next game we will see you all in
just a moment
[Music]
so
and we are back and the players are
ready gigak versus
mother's basement yo let's see in the
chat who
was waiting for this match i
wha how's it how's your boy giga gonna
do
i'm gonna predict too
predicting that right now i i really
think that he's going to do well
yeah i think he's been working a lot and
really working on that 1.5 player just
it's the style that i kind of taught him
uh during our lesson
um that's good also on youtube happy
series
yeah i'm plugging a lot but it's there
yeah definitely go check it out guys
jt's got some good content
and uh we are now ready we're waiting
for the games to begin any moment now
we're gonna kick this thing off two game
mini match just like before
and uh and the winner moves on so
uh as soon as the games get going we
are gonna get going i think the players
look ready sid obviously uh
there with uh higa giving him some
encouragement
and um i i really enjoyed watching
mother's basement do his training as
well that was a lot of fun
um i i i i mean i know i know he's your
student but
i think this one could go either way
both these players have taken this
pretty serious
you're right i'm extremely biased
[Laughter]
checking in behind the scenes here
making sure everything is good to go
and we are off the game has begun
mother's basement starts out with the
white pieces
all right let's see what they choose
okay d4 training has gone
up a lot of reading points actually
yeah everybody seems to have really
really been doing some serious practice
here
okay i'm liking the opening choice
now here's just important to develop
your knight develop your bishop
you know develop your other bishop yeah
very nice developing the knights first
so good structurally we're already good
yep both players developing you know
just those
early principles yeah get access for
your bishop now
oh yeah yep e3 creating you know little
and this is actually called
uh these zuckertor um
variation of the queen spawn opening
it's i think the trigorin variation when
you play the knight c6 right
so very nice um i i'm liking the way
that he's playing here
um now bishop b5 is a very classy move
basically saying hey i'm going to try to
double your pawns
and actually i think we just ignore this
and we say okay we're going to double
our pawns and then we can just play
something like
e6 and if 95 then just play a knight d7
and yeah but it's it's
it's tough here well we'll see
gig's got a decision here to make and
maybe we'll listen in and see
what uh what his thought process is
about how to deal with this oh
oh no let my queen out
putting it right in the path of danger
basically self-pinned i'll move my queen
out then i'll chase his bishop away
i think uh a move like knight e5
really good are you gonna castle that's
what i'm guessing
yeah i would deal with that bishop first
right before putting
anything else in danger
see what he goes for
v castles it will be a pretty smooth
opening for him
yeah i think either castling he's going
to play castle on
c3
yeah knight c3 um and it's not that
accurate i would even play right now i
think this is the perfect opportunity
even though you've moved the bishop
already and we talked about not moving
the bishop or
not moving pieces more than one time i
think it's the perfect opportunity to
play bishop g4 here and not
allow knight e5 um
[Music]
okay a6 which moves back and now we play
b5
actually now i think black is actually
doing great
which is interesting oh that's how that
turned out oh no
oh no
is avoiding 95 like
just avoiding it every single move
yeah you put it here and the the knight
cannot take
and it's a great square for your knight
right right in the center of the board
can't quickly be uh pushed out of the
way by a pawn
right yeah and one of the main ideas is
actually we can even take with the
bishop
and we can try to win a pawn if the
queen's on d8 and if the queen goes to
d6
then we have moves like knight g6 for
example or knight f7
attacking the queen and attacking the
rook with multiple pizzas
right so right
a lot of roads in for mother's basement
maybe we'll take a peek in and see if we
can hear his thought process
i'm gonna bring this a little further up
and put
pressure on that bishop no
i mean then i will potentially trade my
queen
but
okay he's trying to come up with a plan
actually i'm gonna move this here
yes yeah that's still good
and i'm loving how he's thinking he's
like hey i have to keep developing i
have to connect my rooks right
this is an awesome plan i'm not of tell
them where we're going
i'm ready to castle either way yeah he's
realizing he's spending a little bit too
much time go ahead get your king safe
and then
get back to business that's the move i
wanted to see b5
really kind of playing that 1.5 player
chest like we were talking about
[Music]
yep thinking about managing his
opponent's options right
yes exactly exactly
now the bishop needs to retreat right up
oh oh knight even so here we have it
now it's not it's not a complete blunder
yeah right because knight captures e5
and then d captures e5 attacking the
knight on f6
right yeah go ahead and attack with that
pawn instead of taking back with the
bishop and then the knight could just
sit right
right but on knight h5 attacking the
bishop
now we're gonna get the bishop pair
right the bishop is going to move back
to b3 we're going to take on f4
and it's going to get a bit dicey
okay all right so he has to take the
right way he has to take the right way
he has to take with the pawn if he takes
out the bishop he's just losing a piece
well here's a critical moment for gigook
let's uh try to listen in and see if we
can hear him
oh
yeah wow
that was gonna be that's gonna be costly
and now
now giga cuts he's gotta he can turn
this around
okay
yeah so very nice um and so here
now we're kind of looking for trades and
what an amazing turn of events i mean
you're after i don't know
basement still got to decide now he
still has this
this threat right yeah i even think that
we can play on d captures e5
i think we have a very spicy move oh
bishop captures even better
we still have the same move like b4
and the idea is to move the knight from
b4
and then our knight and potentially go
to e4 which is a great score and
especially in these kind of closed
structures
where we have the pawn on like f7 east
uh e6 and d5
and they have that kind of similar pawn
chain moving that knight to
that empty square either e4 uh for black
or
e5 or white with a knight is generally
a good idea and you know if i want to
kick your knight i have to ruin
a little bit of my king safety and then
castle in the other direction
but now i'm telling my opponent where
i'm going
and so here yeah i i love b4 i love the
move b4
or if we want to play 1.5 player chess
then we play c6
okay and we just say hey we don't we
don't need any of this
yeah just solidify yep are our rooks
doing great on the a file
we don't even have to develop it anymore
because it's really it's already
developed
you know we do a little you know castle
we're up a piece we use our extra piece
to our advantage
well let's listen in on giga and see
what he's got going on
yeah i'm running outside let's see what
jeff does on the press show
okay so he's basically saying like i'm
going to control my clock by just
issuing some threats
well i can just move that there though i
don't think that one's very [__]
and it was a slight error and actually
he understood that
but it wasn't a big idea ah this is what
i hate this
this is a lot less time than i'm used to
yeah you kind of have to think about
that right like do i have a follow-up
you know yeah you want to attack but you
also want to have like
you know the next move or two figured
out after that right what is your
opponent's
best response and then what do i do
with that information
i think we have to be really careful um
with the b5 bond because the knight and
queen are attacking it so yeah we have
to be
really careful attacked twice only
defended once right we tell people all
the time
to count the material count the number
of attackers versus the number of
defenders
not only that but you could force a
queen trade right if queen takes
no actually taking is pretty bad because
then we have the
threat of them coming to c7
so take me through that right so queen
captures
on b5 and if queen captures on b5
knight captures on b5 and now we're
threatening a fork on c7
and now the bishop strong okay so
he finds f3 knight captures where b5
right so queen captures b5 queen
captures b5
knight captures b5 and now the knight is
threatening
c7 and the fork as well nasty
all right so let's see what we've got
going on here honestly
the move that i love to play b4 is still
available
or you can play bishop h5 or bishop f5
it doesn't really matter
and we just kind of go back and say okay
i'm sorry
so still plenty of options right yeah
some yeah sometimes i like to say
when they're right they're right
sometimes
you're wrong and you have to accept that
and you just go back and
a lot of the time we have chess egos and
that's something that we talked about in
our lesson
um we talked about people having just
eagles that it's okay to go backwards
and he just gave back the piece oh no
but he might have something tricky here
there's a small trick
if f3 takes on g4 we have knight e4
the same tactic that uh mother's
basement had
now he has it in reverse yes
see if this is very interesting to see
i like how much tension there are in
these games so far i mean like
you know everybody has chances in these
middle games
all right well let's take a peek in and
listen to mother's basement and see
oh yeah what is going on whereas if i
move my
he's got some hype music happening
defending the center pawn is really
important
i think i'm going to do that castles
it's so interesting he castled in this
position where
maybe he didn't see that the bishop was
free
and now here he castled into the attack
remember yeah the rook is still on
he should have taken his bishop right
the rook that
yeah now he realizes he needed that
bishop
there's still the option to do that
and that's just kind of hanging out
there in the middle now not doing much
i'm going to take his bishop
that also opens up here you have a
really strong move
rook captures e2 oh
so strong or knight e4
both of those moves are extremely strong
okay moving the bishop back that looks
fair but actually leaving the bishop
there and
it just destroying their pawn structure
was also a really strong
actually i think it's stronger to give
up the bishop in that case
because we're opening up lines to the
kings right go ahead and just take on b2
maybe
take on a2 instead right we take on
eight
two and if they take on c3 then we're
happy because now our queen can't get in
our knight can go to e4 and attack c3
[Music]
yeah let them weaken themselves
basically right
giga can close this thing out he's got a
lot of choices and a lot of good things
work here
and he's decent on time he's up a minute
so he may have this first game and then
mother's basement gets put in a
must-win situation in the second game
yeah
there's your move yeah yeah 94 is a very
strong move and again in these
structures 94 is perfect because
you want to fill in those squares and
this is called an outpost
and what an output a good outpost is is
is where the pawns cannot attack you
and there are no pawns available to move
this
knight and it's defended by a pawn so we
could sit here for an eternity
until it gets traded off or it exactly
so we don't even have a light square
bishop right
exactly so that's sitting there until
you give me an exchange
that night right there is probably worth
about five points
yeah and that's a level of chess that uh
that people think
you know uh beginners start to develop
an understanding of is you know looking
at the squares and saying like okay if
i've got a light square bishop and
and all of my targets pawns are on dark
squares then
my better or worse is the mobility
better than the
the lack of the ability to capture those
pawns attack those bonds right and so
those those those are like deeper things
than maybe either the players are
thinking about right now
just trying to figure out how to
checkmate right right
and honestly there's a really nice idea
what happens if
uh mother's vaping basement plays bishop
captures on a g7 then we
actually have a very strong move rook
captures a2
threatening checkmate on the next move
oh there we go there we go okay i wonder
if
he's going to see this play your 1.5
player chess don't worry about what he's
doing anymore there we go
there we go there it is
there we go big brain oh this is exactly
what we were talking about in our lesson
destroy their threats and then go for
your plans
this is oh that's so good awesome chess
looks confident on camera you can see
he's sort of swinging
he's he's feeling himself he knows that
he's got
this oh yeah
let's listen in on him and uh and hear
what he's got to say about how he feels
about his position right now
oh boy the king b1 he has to find a
really critical move here
this move is actually really hard to
spot
he has to play
queen c6 here
next closes out because what happens is
queen c6 and if they play
let's say inc takes now we're gonna have
a lot of pressure
on the whole position by playing between
a8 jack and then
maybe a night check coming in queen over
and it's going to be
[__] i've blundered
you you have this in the bag let's see
here oh my gosh
oh my gosh check there if he finds queen
c6
or just moves his truck back but he
hasn't blundered yet
because there's a lot of pressure it
doesn't matter about our king side
anymore
we're attacking on the queen side our
queenside attack is worth
more than a rook right now
well we're here you can identify that
we're hearing uh realizing this myself
in a bad spot
he maybe got overconfident
yeah and sometimes uh material
doesn't really matter when you have an
attack like this
yep keep that momentum going right yeah
so so what you know
you're losing that rook but you have an
attack you know continue to pursue your
plan
fair enough so he played
rook to okay
i mean that's all right right yeah yeah
i think we he still keeps
his advantage but i honestly
okay if we were able to play like
something like queen c6 and
get in there we still have checkmate
opportunities so i like the plan
maybe you know i think if he does review
this game over
and uh looks at it i think that he'll
find
this very very beautiful plan yeah i
mean you know
a little inefficient but that's what you
come to expect i mean the fact is
he's gonna get some time here right this
bishop has to decide what to do
and then that gives you the opportunity
to still make you know a solid move
and he only has 50 seconds left right
that that is also a factor
oh wow yeah mother's basement is
definitely feeling the pressure on the
clock
he has to make all of his moves
basically on increment right now
yeah and and for those of you at home
who don't know
so with the the five second increment
every time you make a move
five seconds are going to be added back
to your clock so if you're running out
of time as long as you keep moving you
can
actually build up a little bit of time
you can you can add to your clock
but obviously if you move too quickly
mistakes
very beautiful nice bishop d6 very nice
i like this and you can either go to the
king side with this or the queen side
and you keeping pressure
and not going to uh a5 which i think
would have been slightly
inaccurate yeah i mean you've got an
attack on this pawn but you're also
you know keeping squares away for the
king
this is good chess mother's basement
down to 10 seconds
oh oh wow living on increment right now
and again the move that i want to see is
b4
rushing has his structure
he and you see that knight there that
knight on e4 controls a lot of the
weaknesses that black has and
white i said and white has no entry
points at all yeah this knight is really
doing a great job
just locking down the position yeah
this works right keep your queen
involved oh there we go
ego has a lot of time oh and he he says
let's
let's let's let's throw in a check then
we'll take the free stuff
hopefully that is as long as he sees it
fingers crossed you have this
yep okay nice nice now you just have to
wrap it up
right and he has he's living on
increment right now
but i mean two and a half minutes also
you know we heard
giga complaining that this is not as
much time as he's used to playing with
so
mother's basement could defend if if he
moves fast enough make safe moves
it's a lot of pressure and there's your
move before yeah
great move break everything open exactly
uh interesting i mean it is a check and
if he takes then
he's even more exposed this is probably
going to lead to a mate
let's see maybe move that f-pawn out of
the way and get your other rook in there
get some access right bring it as long
as we come in a friend
solid as long as we make solid moves
here
we're not losing right we have a rook in
a night and a rook
and we have that night on a beautiful
square that night is holding it down
that night is
worth more than a rook right now just
all the squares that it's covering and
everything that it's doing for the
position right that night is worth
at least of rook in the pawn right now
well let's see if god can figure this
out with uh less than two minutes on the
clock
mother's basement feeling the heat has
to move
fast to try to stay in this and hope
that uh gig either runs out of time or
makes a mistake that helps equalize
okay c5 saying hey i'm going to
try to break stuff open or maybe even
play you know
c4 trying to get the queen in
oh there we go giving up some more
material mother's basement i think is
just
feeling too much pressure here moving
too here we go
if you play kd3 we have c4 check me oh
there we go c4 check me
this is the move if you can find it a
lot of beginners
can't find checkmates with pawns no
he'll see it he'll see it
okay maybe he wants to deliver checkmate
on uh on d1 instead
i'll give him the benefit of the doubt
he wants to check me on the way he wants
to check me
okay yep still happening and we may just
see a loss on time here and we can
time exactly all right gigok gets the
first game mother's basement now in a
must-win position
he's got to win the next game and
is stoked one more he says one more boys
here we go
geek with the white pieces now we gonna
see just some all-out attacking is
he gonna he's gonna take it to the next
level here
and we really worked on his openings and
made sure that he understands like
like that 1.5 player test mentality we
we just stopped your opponent's plans
i really i'm interested in how he plays
looks like i've got to flip my scores
here
there we go
all right and we're off attacking the
center right away
actually part of um here's homework it
was to do tactics but also to play three
minute chess
to get them ready for this faster time
just in case they end up in the
tiebreaker
yep yeah all right so locking down the
center attacking the
the knight oh there we go
now there there's a tactic here isn't
there
missing the free knight on c6
yep three piece
okay here we have a nice tactic we can
play uh
knight captures d4 because it actually
defends on e2 and then the bishop would
be
hanging very nice tactic yes
he sees it and now we take the bishop
for free ouch so we still got
our free piece yeah and and now there's
a loose pond too
yeah and you're also taking away the
right to castle if after the queen moves
right because the king cannot castle
into check
yeah but i don't know if you know g4 is
the best square because
they're probably going to play knight f6
and i think we should just play maybe
bishop f3 or bishop
you know e2 in that scenario bring it
back
yep get your other pieces out finish
your development castle and then
and then just use your advantage right
exactly
there's a really famous saying that you
have you don't have the right to attack
if you're not castled
right and you know usually when people
attack all out before they castle um
they get into trouble because there's
counter attacks you know
the bishop e7 kind of reserved move and
i think here we can just take the pawn
and move away when they attack us yep
and he does so
mother's basement you know get your uh
get your
get your development finished castle and
then regroup right get get your
get your nerves under control and try to
come back into the game
so i think here um we just kind of
really want to trade pieces
although it's not over right this is
still anybody's game it's only a piece
[Music]
and we saw them blunder pieces before so
well he seems to be feeling himself swam
back and forth in his
chair he's comfortable right he knows
that he it'll be a while before he feels
any kind of pressure in this game
yeah now we just need to develop our um
developer pieces we talked about in the
lesson that
uh we need to focus on our opponent's
plans what do they want to do first
we deal with all of their threats and
then we focus on
just going with our plan right if
they're not doing anything okay then we
can just focus on our plan but if
they're doing something
we analyze it and find the best
continuation
and so that was my strategy for him just
going into this tournament
it seems like it's working yeah let's
check in and listen and see what he's uh
what he's what he's feeling right now
this map this man is this man is tilted
to [__] man
oh oh jeff
but be careful gig don't let that
confidence get to your head in that
position oh yeah
threatening this pawn so yeah
i shall reinforce that pawn
okay so he's just going for a stable
development it's good
no need to press just yet right i think
um really reminds me of like maybe
um a younger harp off like
or probably he was like five years old
though just the way he's thinking you
know
it's very prophylactic he just wants to
defend everything and he just wants to
make sure that
they have enough they can't do anything
so
i'm really liking the way that he's
playing now for me i think mother's
basement has a few issues to solve
where is he going to castle right
because that castle's queen side we're
ready to attack
right he must be feeling the pressure
on g8 what future does it have
yeah and i think queen e5
but aren't you just subjecting yourself
to further attacks you know let's say
get the bishop in there and just
continue to develop while also
you know doing so with with tempo right
yeah i think
actually right here queen b5
and then queen captures five i mean
sorry queen b5 and then queen captures
v7 is a
really strong idea yeah yeah go go all
in at this point
your king you know uh could get safe
with a castle but also i mean this is
dangerous right this is also a really
nasty fork
even bishop e3 here just finishing your
development and you don't know which way
you want to castle you're not
telling all this basically where you
want to castle you're just kind of
waiting to see what they do
and nice yeah oh very see yeah very nice
very nice
very good developing move just control
both sides of the board right and make a
commitment
exactly you know we think uh giggers is
just going to go ahead and castle here
just to get that done before the attack
well it's interesting right it depends
on what mothers
i think if we cancel it's a safer route
and i i really
i would advocate for or recommend that
the castle but
it really depends because if he plays a
move like c5 then i'm going queen b5 and
captures b7 i'm in there
yep yeah if i see a castle i'm just
gonna start an attack right
okay so we see h5 i think
even moving the queen to v5 still
because we do have those threats or just
moving the bishop away
you know we don't have to do anything
yep and he
obviously is playing it safe now right
he wants to hold the fact that he feels
in control here and this is
again just like karpov great ideas
very very good ideas yeah and he played
a lot like this during your training
session right a little bit a little bit
more patiently than some of the other
competitors we've seen so far
yeah yeah so actually we have a really
nice move here just bishop captures a7
really really beautiful because if you
try to play b6 here
then queen to uh a6
uh makes a lot of sense yeah and the
king has to go to
d7 again so many ways to get in there
everything
is staring down where you've just
castled it's
that's uh that's rough black might have
been better just staying put
and getting these other pieces active
and into the game and
and uh and solidifying yeah right build
a shelter for yourself if you're feeling
the heat
okay that's also good too now i do not
want it to blunder
moving that night too early
and then use it when it's the most
deadly right yeah
okay so bishop okay this is a really
good move my mother's basement this is
a really good bishop and trading it off
makes sense
and also now you release you're off the
f6 square so now that they can go to f6
and finally you can finish your
development
so it makes a lot of sense
another high quality move
well let's uh listen into mother's
basement for a moment and see what we
can glean
he's really bunched up there okay
i think even though i'm down a piece i'm
in a better position overall
i love the dramatic music oh yeah
i like the curtains i honestly i love
that whole
that whole template and if you want to
follow mother's basement you can go to
mother's basement official
twitch.tv and
follow along from his perspective that's
the threat in that huh
okay now you're basically forced right
you're forced to trade
it's free you know it's still put yeah
f4 i think was a
slight error yeah you get a pawn out of
the exchange yeah i think here
just rook f1
and okay here's fine too we just move
you know queen takes because their
bishop was also their best bishop right
that piece was really strong but as you
can see
a lot of our holes were on dark squares
right so like
uh e3 d4 f4
e5 right so a lot of the squares were
dark and so now that we don't have that
dark square bishop now we have to kind
of find a new way to defend them
okay he pins his own rook to the king
but that's not really an issue right now
right because there's just there's no
other activity you can't bring in
anyone to help exploit that yet right
and you know let's just move that rook
to the f file and
we're good after that
well let's see mother's basement also a
little bit down on the clock
but uh you know the eval says this is
all for white but
i think there's chances for either
player still
this is a really interesting position um
now the rook coming to the f5 is what
i've wanted for a while now
um but now the reason that i wanted it
is because
rook should occupy open files and
if we're just on the h file we're just
looking at a brick wall that h2 pawn
yep and obviously you know make sure
that that rook is defended or it's safe
but uh being the first to that open
space you
you tend to be able to sit on that for a
long time
once you control it and now we should
start attacking right now that we have
the rook on the open file we have all
the resources that we need
i think something like okay g3 perfect
that was a good move
uh stopping their attack um and now
maybe playing like queen d4
um knight b5 really try to get our
pieces in there
and force them to make a mistake yeah
and i mean look how locked out black is
i
cannot get pieces over to the other side
to defend against any kind of attack
right now
you have to get federal recorders do
that you know uh google is playing it
quite fast
quite accurately right so that's one
factor that's going to help them
i think in this tournament in this game
as well
h4 saying you know what let me see if
he'll give me some activity for my rook
right and i'm wondering if mother's
basement comes back
and wins this game gonna have to play a
3-0
and so far good uh giggle is
really up on time i wonder if that's
going to translate into an easy win
i don't know i mean we we heard him say
earlier that
he is really not comfortable in a time
crunch so
all right the attack begins maybe
like you said before save this night and
use your queen
and your other pieces first right and
then and let this be sort of your secret
weapon
but you know now but but but it's not
terrible right because if you move upon
to chase me away then you're also
exposing yourself on that side
i take advantage of that after i get my
my night bike to safety
i wonder what's going through the mind
of uh
mother's basement well let's listen in
music intensifies i gotta learn how to
play this more aggressively
i think like like i gotta learn how to
like trade effectively that's
my big weakness
is he already talking about this game
like it's identified
yeah i think he's he's he's defeating
himself and
we see queen d4 on the board with both
moves that i was recommending earlier
awesome awesome 1.5 style of chess 1.5
player
jrpg plus yeah jrpg plus exactly
oh this is this is tough this is tough
because if you even if you play like a
move like queen to
let's say i'm sorry let's say you play
like queen sorry
i said queen twice there if you play b6
onto b6
then we can play a move like between two
wow wow wow i i wonder if they know the
opposite
i wonder if he knows he's five now the
white yes and white tape
let's go he sees it a rule that a lot of
people a lot of beginners especially
don't remember that if the
if the opponent's pawn tries to skip
past
in order to not be captured on that next
turn you can take as if it had only
moved one space
and now it's busted wide open attack
made in two
there's check made into here let's go
let's go
oh and this is forced
yeah it's forced it's over
he cook has sealed the deal and let's
catch
his reaction but it will be it will be
he has no choice he has to move there
he knows it he knows he's got it in the
bag he's moving on
yep yep only one move
oh and he's savoring it man this win was
so free and i didn't even have to use
coupon choice basement
a little bit of trash talk there i go
there right let's check mate
let me just make sure of this
easy winning
let's go let's go
let's [__] go and there it is it's
over
he celebrates he's moving on we
uh we have at least one member of the
trash taste team
in the semis and there's a little bit of
celebration
mother's basement also seems to be
pretty happy for his opponent
and uh we're gonna check in with both of
them in just a moment everybody stick
around
because in a few minutes few minutes we
will have both players
on camera stay tuned everybody we'll be
right back
[Music]
do
so
[Music]
and we're back with the players
everybody we've got gee [__] and
mother's basement
giga congrats man you are moving on to
the next round mother's basement
uh that was a tough match for you man
how how
how did it how did it feel like it went
for you like tell us a little bit about
that
um well i mean i uh
i still need to really work on my um
mid game and end game um the the
first game i feel like we both got our
our uh
setups done pretty well um second game
um kind of uh bodied me
early on and i feel like i i was a
decent way toward making a comeback but
then
you know like put some pressure on him
in the mid game but then toward the end
came in from the side and uh
wrecked me um well jt let's go through a
few moments of that second game
okay that's fun yeah i think
on move uh five if you can go to that
all right and i'll move five you could
have instead of bishop e2 you could have
just captured on c6
what went through your mind what were
you feeling
um okay
what's up can can you repeat that yeah
so why to move here
this uh this night right here is is free
for the taking
you played this bishop move which is
fine but
um yeah tell us a little bit about that
moment
did you notice that the night was free
i didn't actually okay okay here's the
thing
i i got tunnel visions i totally didn't
know that i could
i totally didn't see i could take it at
night even earlier because all i saw
was that if i
yeah if i i guess all i saw was he was
going to take my night as well and i
forgot that i guess it would be uh i
would be able to trade up there
i i tell ya you're right i totally i
totally did not see that
um i was i was too i was too tunnel
visioned by the pin because i
i hate i i hate this pin where the
bishop pins
bishop pins and knights um so i was
too focused on putting allevia
alleviating pressure on this pin that i
didn't just see the three nights
um yeah i was totally tunnel vision
there
i think um you there was another
opportunity um
later in the game if we can go
i think to move
here i think it's move uh 12.
so instead of bishop e2 you had this
move quite a few times like queen b5
and i actually like your move queenie
bishop e2
because we talked about a lot of like
just defending against your opponent's
threats
yeah and let's just stop the opponent
from doing what they want to do and then
continue with our plan right so you did
that very effectively this game so i'm
really proud of you actually
like you've been amazing um but
queen b5 here because you can ignore
your opponent's stress because we're
checking
first and then we're taking a pawn and
now we're attacking the rook
and then we can move the bishop after
yeah okay that would have been way more
efficient
yeah and especially because after taking
that pawn take the bishop well i get a
rook for it
it's funny because i think i was because
i was pretty nervous i was playing way
more defensively than i usually would
and then i think the turning point was
when
i was like i just got bored of playing
defensively and i was
i was just thinking okay jeff's jeff's
pressuring my left side uh jeff's
pressuring my right side
what would happen if i just ignore that
and just go on the offensive
uh jeff cracks under pressure um and
that's
in the end is what got me the win
because
um i just it was when i started ignoring
my own defense and started going on the
offensive that i actually ended up
i'm in a winning position
and jeff like i you had a really nice
move i think on move
uh 14 or 13 actually sorry with black to
move and you played the bishop
to uh g5 that was a really nice move
because
white has a lot of dark square
weaknesses and you took away their dark
square
bishop right you're pinning it to his
king so that was a really really nice
idea even though
this game was really hard for you to
come back because you lost a piece early
in the game
i think that was a really awesome idea
that you had hey let's get rid of the
bishop because the
bishop is also preventing your knight
from developing right your knight wants
to go to f6 your rooks want to get
active
right so that was the fir that was a
first
step in the right plan to success so
good job in finding that idea
but i i could have followed up on it
better
um it was hard
like i don't even know if i could find
the right plan it was really really hard
but you did what you like that that move
definitely annoyed me i i was trying to
figure out because i didn't i didn't
want to trade bishops but i couldn't
move my bishop
um because now that like you said the
dark square bishop was really important
for me so i that's why i moved my porn
up
and i thought i had forked you i didn't
then take into consideration that you
could just take with the bishop so yeah
you definitely made me panic
yeah i know that was uh yeah that was a
fun mid game um
there was a lot of good like back and
forth there i think um
you really put the pressure on me early
on um
i gotta learn how to deal with that
better uh and
put more pressure on like like moves
like that um
where i where i get the pin and sort of
go on the offensive
um not super good at them
well i'll say that despite the result
there was some seriously
good fighting chess there from both
players i think and uh
so gigguk you move on you will face
the winner of either uh the of the match
first match tomorrow
between rebel house and anime man
between those two opponents we talked a
little bit about this yesterday but i
want to ask you so
how do you feel about uh about your
chances in this next
this next match um i mean
right now i was happy to uh get my first
win that was the
goal um in my next one i mean i
i feel i feel i feel fairly confident
i've played joey before
um and we with the one game we played we
both ended up in a stalemate
um and we played a pretty awful game
and i i kind of want my rematch with
joey
um so i'm i'm cheering for i'm cheering
for my boy joey
so sorry d i love you but i got i got to
cheer for my boy we're going for the
trash taste top three
um also uh dee's been acting very humble
on twitter and everything but i know for
a fact that he's been talking mad trash
behind the scenes
so uh it should be interesting i i know
joey's feeling a lot of pressure because
if dee wins he's never gonna let it down
he's not gonna let joey forget so i
think it should be a very entertaining
game and i'm
very excited to watch it and you know
jeff i want to ask you
like who do you think uh is going to
uh make it all the way to the finals
well i hope that garnt does because
that'll be less embarrassing for me
the further ahead he goes you know i can
i can act like i actually if if gart
wins
technically i kind of got third place ah
i dig that i dig that sound logic
um i mean
conor's definitely uh like i think
favored the to win this thing because
you know he's got that pro chess history
but i patchwolf's a clever bastard
and i think he could he could really
sneak that in
um get a win in there and make it all
the way to the finals
um i wouldn't count him out just yet
uh i agree with that he had his lesson
with uh with
james canty yesterday and uh seemed to
get some solid stuff going on so uh
so we'll see but uh you know my last
question for you
uh is did you have a good time
it was great it was pretty
nerve-wracking before the match started
i think the
worst part was waiting for the match to
start but after
after it started it was it was a lot of
fun
yeah no it was like my heart was racing
through a lot of it uh didn't help that
i put on phoenix wright music
but it was yeah no it was a blast um
and like i i feel like we had like a
proper battle of wits there was some
good back and forth there
um and you know the most important thing
i think is that the people watching
were entertained by it and i think it
was like a really entertaining
game that could have gone either way
a bunch of times and
that is you know i had fun playing it
and hopefully people have fun watching
awesome that's what matters i'm glad to
hear that in jt do you have any last
advice that you're gonna give your boy
before he moves on
just take it a little bit slower i know
you were you know getting that timer
advantage but
really take your time like you played uh
bishop e2 almost instantly after the pin
really take your time because that's
going to affect you later on when you're
facing that competition that's already
once you're going to face the stronger
competition
um so just be careful okay okay
well big thanks to both of you and we'll
let you go and um
uh we'll see you uh we'll see you in a
couple days gig
and mother's basement i'm glad you had a
great time and and we'll definitely be
seeing you around uh on twitch and on
youtube
yeah well i'll see you guys around as
well thank you for having me this was a
lot of fun
thank you very much and uh jeff
good luck seriously thank you
and there you have it you've heard it
from the guys uh gigguk
moves on wins his uh
his first match and um and now
we've got two more matches to go in the
first round we got
anime man and rebel house starting us
off tomorrow
same time 5 p.m pacific and then sea dog
versus super eye patch to follow
jt you heard what they think might
happen but uh we want to hear from you
where where is this competition gonna go
uh i kind of want the trash
to taste top three because i'm the coach
[Laughter]
not biased at all no yeah not biased by
his commentator
but um uh we're gonna have to really
take a look at rebel house and super eye
patch wolf i
really want to see their games and i
think it's gonna be extremely
interesting
what's gonna happen in their games so
i'm excited to watch what's gonna happen
and i hope that all of you are ready
for the amazing chat that's about to
unfold and happen
well tomorrow and yeah with that said i
mean
it it's on it's on tomorrow's gonna be
amazing and and we've got some
some great players that are already in
the semifinals like i i
i'm so stoked man this is this is going
to be fantastic thank you to everybody
who tuned in and hopefully we'll see
every single
one of you back here tomorrow for the
second half
of the opening round of tournament arc
uh thanks to uh jt and also
thanks to everybody behind the scenes
who's helping make this happen and
thanks to the players and
and we'll see you tomorrow have a good
night everybody
[Music]
so
you